the filmmaker said this coffin heist is
so unimportant let's film it and washed
out colors and in weave the opening
credits sequence through it oh and also
kill all the epileptics in the audience
okay things are about to get exciting
truck driving down a mountain road in
Albania intrigue is about to come out of
every corner in this scene oh it's just
a truck delivering comments no one will
be seated during the truck delivers the
coffin scene slow to them previously on
taken what you need to remember is that
Liam Neeson killed everyone not just in
this scene but in nearly all the other
scenes wait all those dudes Liam Neeson
killed in the first movie are being
buried in the exact same remote
mountaintop Cemetery at the same time is
Albania that small will not rest until
his blood flows into this very ground we
will forget that we tried to sell his
daughter into sexual slavery that's
Saturday 2 o'clock
somehow about Lenore and Kim forget that
the obsessive Brian is gonna show up
today to give Kim a driving lesson and
she's gone to her secret boyfriend's
house we're talking one phone call a
rescheduling you had one job she said
her boyfriend man she got over that
kidnapping and sexual slavery thing
really fast wine at 2:00 p.m. suggests
that frequently getting kidnapped is the
least of this family's problems damn
four missed calls how long have you been
making out without making any real
progress to miss four calls the only
thing Liam Neeson is killing in this
scene is the mood also Maggie grace
isn't my girlfriend in the scene of
course she's playing an underage girl
who doesn't even have a license so maybe
she shouldn't be my girlfriend in the
scene but then I'm gonna send it for
having Maggie Grace play a 16 year old
with a straight face
so movie is fucked either way GPS I had
it installed in your phone also nope -
Kim don't leave naked pictures of
yourself on this phone he will look for
them he will find them and he will kill
them here are some nice scary stories of
goings-on with people your age you know
like the movie taken perfect why
couldn't you do that in the test maybe I
didn't really want a license is it the
character that really doesn't believe
what she just said
or is it the actress listen of course I
know where you're coming from
but you've gotta trust me to figure this
out what the driving or the sex and
don't go running a background check on
him with your friends I won't because I
already have ha ha ha
meanwhile in Paris rise I don't know how
did the Albanian dudes even know this
guy was a friend of Neeson's I'll forget
it I'm sure that's not imported all do
they believe he actually knows Brian's
address or something I mean even if he
says Los Angeles are they gonna be able
to look him up in the phone book like
The Terminator did and how many Bryan
Mills are in LA anyway way more than the
three Sarah Connors I'm sure why don't
you and Kim come with me
sure what the fuck you said earlier
you're going to Istanbul right and
you're both the ex-husband and
overbearing father to these two sounds
perfect let's drop everything and do
this thing you're suggesting well it
just wouldn't be a-takin movie if we
didn't bring back Bryant's bullsh Army
bodyguard friends over a lousy looking
cookout now would it
so what John clot told this guy I don't
know where he is but there's a guy in
Albanian who totally does go find him it
sure is lucky to Brian had a job in
Istanbul or else how what these guys
ever find it all so how does this random
unknown unexplained Albanian asshole
know anything about Brian's security
detail in Turkey I mean this is nonsense
right he's humble not Constantinople
welcome to Istanbul prepare to die
hey need a generic Eastern Bloc bad guy
hire this guy he always kills in that
roll the dough thought is thin hill so
what why are these Albanian revenge
assholes talking to each other in
English was he telling us clay okay
how is Brian able to use the driver's
side mirror from the backseat to realize
they're being followed honey there's no
time for this there wasn't time to say
someone's following us Wars night Brian
now tells Lenore she needs to act casual
walk through the market take a taxi get
back to the hotel and call security but
why can't he go with her the bad guys
have lost them nowhere near them instead
Brian decides to take the bad guys
through downtown Istanbul and engaged
with them instead of simply ducking into
the market with little war losing them
completely daughters man
does this girl ever have a ringer on 90%
of the trouble she's in always comes
back to the fact that she can't hear her
damn phone also if you can't get in
touch with Kym why doesn't he call the
hotel security on his own and tell them
they have a problem make sure his
daughter is safe and tell them to guard
both the rooms bad guys instructed to
take Bryan alive start shooting while he
had his windshield oh you nobody saw him
go out the other door you guys ran into
him with a van pointed forward you
somehow missed a door opening you
assholes couldn't even see Bryan leave
the car earlier you're just gonna figure
out where he went and find him just like
that
also Bryan is an expert badass as we've
seen time and again doesn't he know to
take the inside track of the stairs to
avoid being seen just in case this very
thing happened hey how about not running
like a guy being chased also convenient
box warehouse is convenient we interrupt
this taken movie to bring you born the
retirement years
oh look Ines five calls from my dad oh
this chick really hates phones doesn't
she how do these bad guys who just
captured Lin were 10 blocks away nowhere
these bad guys are who just found Liam
Neeson but sure go ahead and make any
phone call you need to right now listen
to me your mother and I are being held
at gunpoint and even though there's no
reason for them to allow me to do so
they're letting me make this phone call
also movie finally gets Kim to answer
her phone but does it at a moment where
the phone call shouldn't even be allowed
to be made roll credits previously on
taken also why isn't she already taken I
have hundreds of guys trying to catch
Bryan but wouldn't have been easy to
just take her already and maybe it
would've been easier to take him if he
knew they already had her guys guys guys
I have one more phone call to make so
did these guys need to take a lunch
first before coming to kidnap Kim she's
things alone
pork lunch - no she's at the pool which
these bad guys should already know
because of that one dude in the lobby
who already noticed she was staying
behind right I mean if you have enough
henchmen standing by to send this many
guys to this hotel to get the daughter
and fuck you know enough henchmen for
her to just have been followed from the
moment that dude knows she was staying
behind
two three brian talks out the time the
directions and one years instead of just
keeping it to himself but figures if the
bad guys are gonna let make phone calls
they'll let him do anything kid in
danger who's tired of waiting for the
elevator will now conveniently decide to
take the stairs
I don't know gosh don't look Oh school
Oh minute bye boy alright why isn't
anyone checking the dad's room right now
anyway you have more than uh guys to
take down someone of her size to be
checking every single place all at once
keycard suddenly doesn't work because it
senses fear
boom you mean this guy doesn't know what
happened to everyone's phones take them
to the show did this Albanian revenge
been asshole hire and all
english-speaking crew for this job or
what it's not like the movie hasn't
shown us Albanian people speaking
Albanian with English subtitles because
it has ah birds the screenwriters
bestfriend harbingers of fake tension
and creators of jump scares so not a
shoe in a hotel room well that
definitely means the girl went out the
window next door window luckily opens
for Kim when she needs to get to the
next room I mean this is Brian's freakin
room right he'd leave the window
unlocked like this these assholes risked
their lives because they found a
flip-flop it takes an average of two
point four years to open a closet door
also this random asshole died at the
exact right time so that Kim could live
seems like a fair trade to me I mean
getting us way hotter than him scaredy
guys show up right as the bad guys meet
at the elevator well this shouldn't be
an easily escapable situation it was
definitely no need for a pat-down
seriously did they not hear all the
stuff he didn't take him they can track
his ass down through the thinnest of
leads but they can't do basic things
like taking a phone away from and also
why not have someone on the inside
watching him outside sure but you can't
spare one guy to watch him on the inside
it's bad enough Brian put this bullsh
bonus lit before going out to dinner
with his ex-wife but then the movie goes
and gives us this hacky sack bullsh
Brian is apparently pay laid out of the
closet safely man how unfortunate that
the bad guy bent on revenge decides to
just put Brian and unmonitored holding
cell for a while so he has time to give
his daughter directions I wanted to go
to the balcony with her
is there a safe place you can throw it
in downtown Istanbul sure lots of places
run back into the hall
keep the phone on so I could hear the
explode why the fuck do you think you
need to instruct her not to turn off her
phone is she in any danger of hanging up
right now cops investigating a murder
don't notice this chick speeding away
down the hallway Kim just happens to
find an open locker with clothes the
fitter in record time come to take you
to Tripoli does this guy realize how
stupid that just sounded I'm here to
take you to another place to kill you
why these guys didn't already just go
ahead and start taking him there is
beyond it in one's comprehension if this
dude's plan is to take Brian back to
Albania to face the people whose lives
he ruined why waste time with this cut
your wife and make you watch her die
bullshit is it just so came as time to
get there and save them nothing happened
to you or to her I promise uncapable
promises the girl has gone I'll be back
as soon as we get her don't move why are
you leaving you never lifted a finger
this whole movie now you're leaving
because Brian's about to go Liam Neeson
on all these assholes and the movie
still needs a villain later even in an
emergency it's a dick move to stiphu cab
driver furthermore the villains decide
to go with the tie the hero up in a
place where you can easily cut his bones
manure
I mean manoeuvre set off another grenade
cam in her father or dicks to Istanbul
Kim sets off live grenades at the main
is Stan bull market place and no police
come looking for but you can bet your
ass the bad guys had been here it and go
looking for without even looking Kim
throws another grenade it probably
killed a family of four but thank God
she can find her dad now the autumn shit
was going on more Albanian bad guys in
Istanbul speaking to each other in
English oh wow now isn't this just the
MacGyver of all holding cells as Brian
fishes for whatever gun part he needs
the holding cell suddenly has numerous
corridors the bad guys need to navigate
before getting inside all right
Liam Neeson is finally killing people in
the scene you know when we did Skyfall
we gave it a sin for ripping off this
rooftop location from taking - now that
we're doing taken to it we're giving it
a sin for ripping off the location from
Skyfall that makes you laugh awesome if
it makes you rage at the inconsistency
well also awesome I asked just what this
movie needed a rooftop chase jumping
from roof to roof tell me when this gets
exciting I'm gonna go use the bathroom
real quick one bad guy jumps but
clotheslines himself on some kind of
wire when 2nd guy jumps though there
aren't even any wires anywhere that
could possibly have snagged the other
dude these assholes went through a maze
of rooftops and had a huge head start
but whatever he was gonna kill her
anyway because bad guy
she's safe she's safe back at the
Holdings Oh barely conscious
with the main bad guys still running
around but safe otherwise this taxi
driver just leaves his keys in the car
because when you're a busy taxi driver
like he is you don't have time to pull
the keys out that are safely in your
pocket
I know these assholes back aren't they
looking for Kim and we know they didn't
find her because she was here the whole
time and no one called them because
Brian killed them all so shouldn't they
still be searching for why even bother
turning off the ignition
you know the car's not gonna start when
you need it and she's gonna need to get
out of here in five minutes anyway Brian
keeps leaving his hot female family
members alone in dangerous settings why
did the Albanians keeping Lenore alive
or keeping her at all they come back
find all their buddies dead the main
captive is gone and their first move is
grabbed the bleeding woman whose
ex-husband didn't even want her suddenly
badass Liam Neeson who can cut down a
gazelle from 300 yards with an ice pick
can't hit bad guys tires when it matters
what the fuck is this asshole doing
remember he left because Kim was still
out there and they went to go find her
but now he's at that house where his
base of operations is he hasn't even
gone back to check on Brian and Lenore
he decided up I need to sit down in the
chair for a while almost getting revenge
is exhausting funny this car started up
so easily when Brian's stolen a minute
ago and these guys these guys are just
sitting around - the search for Kim must
have consisted of yelling out the street
Kim Kim and getting no answer they gave
up okay all these cops heard was that an
officer was down and they started
driving toward the area I haven't heard
anything about a taxi being at the scene
or what the taxis call numbers are but
here they are spinning their car to stop
a taxi for no reason in the middle of
the road where did these assholes come
from all right those guys are dead where
did these assholes come from this is the
toughest damn taxi I've ever seen
doesn't get in any way damaged after all
the police chasing getting hit running
into fences and smashing through gates
how are you missing it's not a car chase
if there's not suddenly a train that
threatens to smash both cars don't worry
I'm sure there are more bad guy vehicles
ready to pop out of nowhere in a few
seconds
don't stop why do you need to do this
the bad guys behind you are dead now
that you're at the embassy chill the
calper wants call someone to make sure
we don't get shot I still don't
understand why you did this maybe you
were worried about the taxi being wanted
by cops but why didn't you just make the
call after the bad guys were dead and
ask your buddy for a favor before
smashing through the entrance also
that's a pretty big favor Sam's about to
pull off with a simple phone call I mean
they nearly killed a bunch of soldiers
with that stunt after crashing a car
through the gate of the US Embassy Brian
apparently was simply allowed to leave
rather than answer any angry military
questions about his actions previously
on taken to he's my daughter is still
alive why would you say this fortunately
for Bryan all the same sounds that were
being made along his kidnapping around
are once again being made slowest
torture ever hello that sounds like an
albanian dog barking metal gates that
should definitely be creaky ghosts I
went to help Brian go splinter cell and
gain stealth points for this takedown
can't we have a bad guy who's not also a
rapist for once never once is there a
guy facing the door when Brian comes
walking through it
Brian reaches deep into his bag of
tricks and pulls out a WWE sleeper home
funny I miss the tires a minute ago so
stranger aim came back when it comes to
hitting a guy five floors up behind a
railing you had him only had to do was
sit here and wait until he walked by and
then BAM he's dead but no you stuck your
arm out for some reason what the fuck
also where did all these guys come from
Brian killed all those dudes back at the
shop and two van loads of assholes got
smoked before they destroyed the US
Embassy but now there's a hundred other
guys to kill all of them could have been
used to better effect earlier to guard
Brian or find Kim but instead they're
here totally whacking off until Brian
showed up I'm glad to see that the Brian
walks through the nondescript hallways
scenes that we enjoyed from the first
movie made it into the second one as
well neither of these guys shoots right
now forget those weapons we're fist
fighting cliche
Oh Albanian henchmen are worthless until
you get to the penultimate bad guy who
was a sudden badass you have other sons
and if I kill you they will come on seek
revenge they will for sure why aren't
they in on this revenge party then with
this I am done taking three also Liam
Neeson would be great at cinemasins
Lenore wakes up and starts talking just
after all the killing is completed
because we care about Brian's personal
life movie refuses to end at the natural
place this touching driver's test
father-daughter moment reminds me of the
father-daughter bonding moment at the
end of the first movie when you took her
to a pop stars house to sing for
whatever happened with that when she's
mad at singing us I think she was I'm
sorry Ron just order three Oh actually
the order said four i order the fourth
one that's cute but even though I know
you want to surprise your parents with
the boyfriend showing up this is a
pretty fucking stupid way to do it yeah
we're just three weeks removed from a
second traumatic experience in our lives
sit down let's have a damn shake why
don't we that don't shoot the
one I really like Brian has never shot
any of your boyfriend's
he shoots bad guys this is one of the
laziest let's give the family a nice
laugh as we pan back pieces of dialogue
ever written you ready when I am I need
you to be ready if I need you to be
ready
[Music]
welcome to Istanbul Istanbul is
Constantinople now Istanbul no concept
you know
[Music]
what are you gonna do I'm gonna steal
the Declaration of Independence
oops bull words stupid hands what did it
sound like you have no idea at all where
they took you
no they threw me in a trunk drove around
in circles it could be a hundred miles
away it could be next door could be
underground it could be in a skyrise
forget it well do did you go over any
speed bumps gravel uh how about a bridge
bridge yeah four bridges in the Bay Area
now what bumps rough ones and then what
did you hear
cocktail party what drove through what
sounded it sounded like a cocktail party
Wow you've got something in common
we both do like guns you're not having
any fun are you Shawn watch come with us
try terrorism for Harwood blow some
stuff it's more fun the moral of the
takin series is really well don't travel
anywhere but if you have to travel I
think the secondary more lose bring
snacks Brian and his ex-wife head out to
dinner and all hell breaks loose and
then before you know what they're
fighting for their lives without the
energy and nutrients provided by the
tasty snacks at naturebox at naturebox
competence Brian could have stocked up
on peanut butter and jelly granola
cheesy pretzels and a host of other
delicious snacks that would have
provided nourishment and given him an
edge over his attackers hell they let
him make that phone call to Kim he
probably could have ordered some
naturebox right then I mean it wouldn't
deliver instantly because physics but
then the next time Brian's hot family
members get in trouble abroad he'd be
ready naturebox comments if there are
delicious snacks available to be
delivered once a month with free
shipping and there are I will find them
and I will eat them
[Applause]